enora on est très content que vous soyez
là ce soir ici parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu une très grosse rumeur qui
m'a fait très très peur un ce matin sur
twitter rumeur relayée par france info
donc ça ça a été vraiment le pire y est
ce que pouvait rappeler ce qui est
arrivé à ainhoa ce matin je crois que
vous êtes au courant voilà deux de la
sphère alors racontez pas trop alors
merci dans la vie j'ai peut-être un
container c'est bien mais c'est ma
période un tweet il ya eu un tweet qui
annonçait que le conjoint d'enora si je
ne prends les mots exacts étaient
retranchés chez elle et l'avait
poignardée exactement donc avéré après
la police voilà c'est ça derrière c'est
un journaliste de france info qui des
infos exclusives france à faut donc
c'est qui ce mec là qui disent ah voilà
c'est lui d'ailleurs qui envoie le pays
qui dit infos exclusives le compagnon de
l'animatrice et laura malagré a appelé
la police donc pour dire qu'il venait de
poignarder la jeune femme c'est un
garçon donc de france info olivier les
106 voilà donc est donc très
sérieusement on a tous pris l'info donc
voilà très au sérieux ce qu'on se dit
france info votre même votre maman il
aura là je vais m'adresser à ce monsieur
cet abruti pardonnez moi parce que moi
pendant quelques minutes
j'essaie de pas pleurer ma mère a cru
que je venais de me faire poignarder
alors mon gars tu vas rentrer à carte de
presse et puis tu vas faire correctement
tant que cela je suis désolé cyril vous
pouvez comprendre au gouvernement
manon je suis désolé cyril à vous
imaginer ma mère et vous le savez qui
vient pendant quelques minutes
l'imaginent que ma que je suis preneur
départ mon contrat il n'a pas eu d'infos
puisque si nous n'aurait pas tweeté
cette bêtise il aurait fallu se
renseigner et faire son travail parce
que ya moi et puis à ma famille derrière
et mes amis qui se sont inquiétés parce
qu'il ya une alerte info que vous avez
tous reçus donc non je suis en bonne
santé
personne ne m'a poignardé je suis en
sécurité on s'occupe de la sécurité et
la personne qui a voulu se faire mousser
en faisant ce canular débile va être
très prochainement appréhender c'est
vrai qu'en ce moment il ya une telle
accélération de la diffusion
d'information fantaisie sur les réseaux
sociaux
donc il faut vraiment que les
journalistes fasse gaffe voilà qu'on
balance pas des trucs et c'est à moi
même aussi loin qu'ils aient rillieux
voilà ouais là c'est pas possible
possible pas faire bien
comme la fp dimanche avec la mort de
martin bouygues le patron de nous doit
la dodo bouygues et tf1 c'était
n'importe quoi perd une minute ou deux
ou cinq minutes ou six minutes mais on
vérifie une source fiable à 100 tous
avaient servi de leçon justement après
martin bouygues
enora la cdac dans malheureux et
peut-être qu'on va apprendre aussi à
prendre avec un peu plus de précautions
tout ce qui est sur twitter à sur les
réseaux wi gens me jean-michel pour
apporter quelque chose à ce qu'a dit
gilles il ya une mode aux états unis qui
commence avec ses parts france qui
s'appelle le souhait thing
kiko soit du nom soit qui est le service
de police américain at t il soit qu'une
intervention voilà qui consiste à
appeler la police pour dire à tel
endroit il ya un talent qui menace
quelqu'un etc
intervenez vite et donc la police
évidemment par principe de précaution
arrive rentrer défoncent les portes et
sa voix pour rien des canuts là et il
faut savoir qu'en france on risque
trente mille euros d'amendé et deux ans
de prison si on s'amuse à faire sa part
parce qu'on soit des phrases iront
retrouver exactement donc à votre porte
n'a pas été défoncé mais la police est
venu chez vous la police est venue chez
moi
ils ont pris ça très gros dispositif
très traumatisant et la personne en plus
continuer à faire le malin mais elle va
être présentée parce que la police est
formidable ici elle réagit au quart de
tour
puis j'ai su le groupe canal pays qui
s'occupe de ma mère aimait merci et ben
voilà on est content voilà vous soyez en
sécurité la vie rémi garde et d'orages